alors que le monde entier continue sa
course au vaccin et tentent d'échapper à
la propagation de nombreuses variantes
qui n'est dans le monde voilà que le
variant brésilien fait beaucoup parler
les variants font des ravages au brésil
faux culs maintenant s'inquiéter du
variant brésilien qui serait encore plus
contagieux s'il est jusqu'à maintenant
très peu diffusé sur le territoire
français les autorités n'ont pas
l'intention de laisser ce variant se
propager dans l'hexagone si aujourd'hui
il est obligatoire d'obtenir un test pcr
négatif pour voyager en provenance du
brésil
le président de la commission médicale
d'établissement ap-hp jusque cela n'est
pas suffisant
si la contamination a lieu dans les
trois quatre jours précédant le voyage
ces tests ont toutes les chances d'être
négatif
seul un isolement contrôle et de 14
jours et turcs cet après midi jean
castex a annoncé la suspension
temporaire des vols entre le brésil et
la france nous avons dans décidé de
suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les
vols entre le brésil
alors faut-il avoir peur du variant
brésilien alors jean castex il annonce
en direct il dit je vais me présenter
aux promesses
les cauchemars algérie sur air france et
surtout les personnes qui vont aux nerfs
n'ont profité de plateaux repas
végétariens sont déconnectés but d'aider
jamais vu un mec c'est ça comme ça alors
faut-il s'inquiéter du variant brésilien
là on va avoir des réponses
on a la chance d'avoir ludovic toro avec
nous et fabrice di vizio avocat qui a
énormément travaillé une fois il a
notamment la chtouille et vous alors
vous avez carrément année l'encyclopédie
universalis quelqu'un doute je sors le
papier non mais sans rire vous avez
c'est le truc d'harry potter
non je réponds c'est quoi alors c'est
depuis à chaque fois que je viens et les
gens qui aiment du manioc est ce que tu
dis c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai et
j'ai surtout aimé franck n'est pas sorti
si le livre de mon frigidaire
moi je suis médecin généraliste
vaccinent depuis le 26 février
donc j'ai fait un livre s'il trouve un
éditeur tu me trouves où chaque semaine
jamais en fait le nombre de flacons que
j'ai reçu dans mon frigidaire une
semaine de stage commence à être content
après 1 et 2 puis 0
sinon vous l'acompte vaccin 0 ça c'est
mon livre d'un médecin généraliste de
seine-saint-denis qui vaccinent et
d'ailleurs je vais vacciner à 21h à mon
cabinet à quoi tu atteins atteint à pas
lent alors j'en ai pas j'ai reçues il a
enfin un flacon donc ce soir je vais
vacciner mais le problème et vous allez
le voir j'ai appelé les patients j'avais
sans passion qui voulait se faire
vacciner pour avoir les 10 ce soir sur
astrazeneca avoué pas vous imaginer la
difficulté c'est à dire que j'ai je
disais souvent sur les plateaux il faut
que vous veniez aux médecins
généralistes pour essayer de convaincre
les gens parce que les machines aux
drones ces morts auxquels vos pas y
aller je mets le paquet influencer les
gens c'est mes patients depuis 30 ans là
c'est qu'on voit en confiance c'est quoi
jeudi passé lastras a
je vous promets je vous voyais je
m'engage je vous promets venez venez
jouve a été et ce soir pour en avoir dix
mais j'ai dû convaincre qu'ils
pourraient vacciner à l'astra zeneca là
je les fais moi non mais ce nom mais
qu'est ce qu'il ferait bernard montiel
bien sûr d'accord ok alors moi je dirais
que toute personne fasse on le savait
depuis le début je veux dire on découvre
on savait que les gens plus jeunes
réagissait plus violemment parce qu'une
unité supérieure
c'était acté depuis le début d'accord
donc plus vous êtes âgé plus vous
n'aurez pas ses effets la d'accord c'est
clair maintenant je vous rappelle 16 17
1 millions ça pique les yeux
quand aujourd'hui on a pratiquement 100
millions de décès en france là c'est à
dire mais sauf que les annonces et
d'ailleurs dans ma vie que je pense
qu'il faut arrêter cette fabrique jamais
rien dire tu veux on a compris on a
compris qu effectivement on est variable
par les patients on est là pour parler
du variant brésilien on a confirmé un
bond à gaz on a compris que tu veux
signer tout le monde qu'elle sera cédée
carrière est allé serrer le dollar est
d'accord il ya des trois ans répond ok
répond quand même se retourner je pose
une rave on peut se demander
raisonnablement il est en train de faire
du commerce ou sur un train de faire de
la médecine est ce que il avec toro se
transformer en vrp d'astrazeneca
non non mais parce que commencer ptc de
quoi j'ai se répéter une chose c'est
tous les jours il ya eu 350 morts mais
j'attends les travaux de pose des
questions je suis vrp dans les vidéos
journée d'hier mais non encore un nom
dix mille décès non mais vous verrez
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus jeunes
lui donner l'âge moyen sur ce plateau
avec les sélections travers de superbes
et de personnes
je suis juste et je le dis très
clairement quelqu'un qui veut vacciner
parce que awa sy faisait défiler ça on
n'a pas pris l'astra saison la combler
astrazeneca a eu plein de l'attaqué je
pense que ça va être très compliqué
alors on sait surtout que je vous
appelle que johnson johnson qui arrive
et est sur le même jaune il a été bloqué
aux étages va faire qu'on va recevoir
enfin jsk sera content de ce qu'on dit
là les autorités sanitaires
effectivement bloc des vaccins parce
qu'elles estiment que la balance
bénéfice risque n'est pas en faveur du
bénéfice et ludovic toro médecin
généraliste m'explique effectivement lui
c'est mieux que d'autres sanitaire et
que c'est scandaleux de bloquer un
vaccin on va tout ce qu'elle a dans ce
cadre
zone ablement et ben ali dont on n'est
pas au marché aucun moment donné cette
histoire c'est elle et elle est sérieuse
ou un bénévole de vic
oui il ya eu des morts mais en
l'occurrence et vol victorieux opération
h10 actuelle je me permets de te
rappeler que la question de la mortalité
est une question sérieuse si tu veux on
peut en parler ou les anglais disent
aujourd'hui que la majorité des vaccinés
enfin mme ashton et d'essai durant cette
vague
elles émanent des vaccinés quel est
l'axé c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
l'autorité qui sont sa part avoir digéré
voire aucun un peu de sérieux
aujourd'hui toutes les autorités
sanitaires disent qu'il faut faire de
l'astra cdk faut pas dire n'importe quoi
raconte l'habileté s'interdisant l'idée
on a tout gagné est d'accord soit l'idée
c'est de la propagande la non là on
évolue on est venu pour parler du vallon
alors qu'à un moment si on part dans les
environs brésilien a grossi sont
paraît-il alors la plus touchée combien
de temps pour l'histoire un tas de temps
vas-y ok donc ce qu est ce qui se passe
vous connaissez un peu moins sur la
route depuis le début ça n'existe pas le
vide personne n'est mort trois fils et
traite même son peuple de pleurnichards
pleurnichard aujourd'hui derrière
enquête sénatoriale d'ailleurs t il
dépêché pour voir un peu le père richard
qu'est ce qu'il en est ça tape à fond le
premier coup et évidemment quand il n'y
a pas assez de vacciner trop de virus il
ya les variants amazoniens qui arrive
le problème se trouve à riom amazonien
il est beaucoup plus agressif
aujourd'hui et tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure
50% des ré a cédé moins de 40 ans ça
rigole plus c'est pas bon ça coince et
on a vacciné surtout avec en fait le
vaccin le moins efficace la mort tel
vaccin chinois mois et d'ailleurs les
autorités sanitaires chinoises eux mêmes
ont dit que c'était pas bon ben voilà
les pauvres ils sont en grande
difficulté mais vous le savez pour aller
au brésil on va pas prendre la voiture
on va pas prendre le train on prend
l'avion
donc ça fait des mois parce qu'il est
arrivé en décembre au brésil
et chez nous est arrivé en février en
février on sait très bien que ce variant
est plus agressif de parts déjà l'âge et
la rapidité des provocations que
l'onglet ah oui oui au niveau de l'âge
vous voyez on est le vario en fait c'est
des courses de variants
en fait en trop mais il faut les courses
c'est ils sont plus agressifs plus
rapide
ils mangent les autres chez nous si
c'est passé longueuil est arrivé d'en
manger l'autre c'est çà et là bas bah le
matériel
après qu'est ce qu'il fait il va prendre
l'avion parce qu'il peut pas prendre le
bateau va prendre la voiture
il prend tranquille l'avion qu'est ce
qui va arriver bien sûr le premier au
portugal parce que les relations entre
le portugal et poignets on est à 25 % de
variants brésilien au portugal
est-ce qui est ce qui l'est plus et ce
qui est plus virulent willy brésil est
plus contagieux sont alors il est plus
virulent et plus pour manger et
d'ailleurs il est plus mortelle oui
parce que quand tu commences à toucher
du jeune ça veut dire qu il est quand
même plus violent parce que les jeunes
ont beaucoup plus d'immunité que les
vieux c'est le principe c'est pourquoi
nous les enfants et les vieux je
commençais un peu mieux par rapport à
vous non mais les vieux vont toucher en
premier bon parce qu'on a moins
d'immunité merci beaucoup
donc ce que je veux vous dire pas tout
ça est une logique et accompagnés de
professeurs médecins
c'est une logique implacable il arrive
au portugal à 22 qu'est ce que fait
portugal vite fait on arrête les avions
mais bien de faire en moselle on est au
même taux qu'au portugal à 22 et je n'ai
pas senti la nouvelle qu'on nous a dit
surtout ne mettez pas d'astrazeneca en
moselle c'était le message qui disait
très clairement que est en éveil
astrazeneca est moins efficace que la
règle on sait depuis deux ans le temps
sur les variants donc il est chez nous
et qu'est ce qu'on fait on leur dit
quand vous arrivez vous restez chez vous
chez vous de quoi
qui c'est qui les contrôlent c'est ce
qu'ils font en israël ils mettent des
bracelets c'est à dire que quand vous
mettez quelqu'un en quarantaine ou le
surveiller parce que dira canadien tu
restes chez toi il faut juste aller voir
ses déchets et c'est quelque chose qui
est pas vrai qu'on va y arriver dur et
l'huile ludovic juste une petite
question qui va je pense qu'ils avaient
la même question que moi je suis
division fabrice elles sont vos souvenez
vous venez de dire non vous venez dire
hein pas quelles sont vos sources
vous venez dire ce bonne question que
l'astra zeneca n'est pas efficace sur
les variants lmh donc à quoi ça sert de
se révéler très énervé il est moins
efficace sur les variants c'est pour ça
qu'on le fait parmi les fils gardien
rencontre sur le vario anglais glaçant
accord mais pas vous savez les ja le sud
façon je veux dire une chose moi j'étais
quelqu'un qui était mon confident
vaccine je commence un peu à perdre
espoir c'est pas du tout mes chances je
vais vous dire et le vivre avec le virus
qui me gênait en tant que médecin mais
qui me gêne et d'une façon je commence à
me dire que vu qu'on n'a pas été
efficace on risque de se taper
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui c'est un
pandémie mondiale dans chaque point il y
aura pas une vaccination et on dira que
ça sert à rien ça va développer
mais quand on va remettre les transports
ou voiliers vont pas arriver ils vont
arriver aujourd'hui la population
mondiale est vaccinée à 1,2 pour cent
vous rendez vous alors nous on va être
vaccinés l'europe mais quand vint
invariants va arriver mais celui qui est
arrivé de chine comme il arrivera
d'autre part voilà donc aujourd'hui
d'urgence mais attends muscat sec s'est
énervé parce qu'il n'y a aucun vaccin
qui sera efficace contre tous les
variants on dit aujourd'hui que les arn
soit un peu plus protecteur et on risque
sur le browser pas fighter et modern age
sont un peu plus efficace et à mon avis
comme c'est parti à moins que je me
trompe et touchant bull j'ai peur on se
retrouve dans un peu comme pour la
grippe en face des vaccins régulièrement
sur un nouveau variant j'aimerais qu'on
explique aux téléspectateurs non un
instant quelle est la différence entre
eux
l'outsider et l'astra zeneca arn
messagers n'existait pas avant et c'est
vraiment un super progrès qui va nous
aider pour d'autres mélodies russes on
parle du match iv parce que peut-être
qu'avec 700 on va pouvoir trouver enfin
à 1 jeudi à rabat que ça parce que ça
fait quand même que cette pandémie
exactes depuis plus de 30 ans d'accord
mais on a toujours un club parce que la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
est-ce que si je me fais vacciner
ça va ça va avoir je vais pouvoir être
activé contre tous les variants qui vont
arriver parce qu'on n'en voit arriver
tout le temps non c'est pas possible de
dire ça d'ailleurs
pfizer et en temps de travail et
éventuellement sur de nouveaux variants
on peut dire juste que les minutes et
qui est fabriqué par la rn messager par
rapport aux traditionnels qui sont
astrazeneca et johnsen donne un peu plus
d'immunité et donc combattre à un peu
mieux mais si vraiment le virus il
change complètement avec les spike et où
il faudra un autre vaccin est d'ailleurs
faite dans la lancée qui éventuellement
dans trois et ils peuvent les faire très
rapidement donc ce qu'est ce qu'on
savait ruisselle je sais qu'ils peuvent
le faire assez rapidement parce qu'ils
peuvent modifier assez rapidement les
vaccins mais oui ce qui veut dire qu'on
va se faire vacciner tous à l'écouté
c'est vous savez moi au début je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure les choses il faut
qu'il y ait plus de pandémie et plus
rien j'y crois de moins en mois parce
que quand je vois seulement 2 % avouent
même pas à 1.5 peu plus la population
mondiale vacciner je me dis que les
variants ils vont faire comme au brésil
ils vont commencer à aussi plus vous en
aurez plus ils vont avoir des plus durs
et qui vont arriver chez nous j'ai peur
de ça est vraiment j'étais pas dans ce
petit qui encore quelques mois mais on
va y arriver on va plier l'anglais on va
plus en parler et tout le monde doit
faire vacciner on s'en rend bien compte
mais au niveau de la france au niveau
mondial on n'est pas à la hauteur en
termes de maximo n'a on a on a trop
tardé à fermer
il est arrivé en france 2 février
d'accord et vous avez là la différence
par rapport à l'aéroport ce cas tu es
l'italie pas venir on n'est pas obligé
de tout complètement con tout le temps
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé
moi j'en avais un nom mais pas comme ça
ses sourires ses conneries tout à
l'honneur de journée sans rien lire sans
rien écouté et [ __ ] je veux dire à mes
attentes et un toit deux minutes et il a
parlé pendant un quart d'heure non c'est
bon j'ai d'ailleurs en italie
effectivement il s'est passé un scanner
par m d'ailleurs c'est que au départ
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et à lire
cette bande de cons ils ont fermé
bah oui on avait dit en italie les
scientifiques italiens tout le monde
avait dit qu'il fallait pas le faire
d'accord mais effectivement personne ne
lit rien écrit rien il avait fait quoi
et de l'historien qu'est ce qu'ils
avaient fait ils ont fermé les liaisons
entre pékin et rome
qu'est ce qui s'est passé eh ben ils
sont tous passés par le hub européen et
donc concrètement les mecs qui étaient à
pékin ils sont passés par les pays bas
ils sont passés par l'allemagne
et ils sont arrivés en italie sans qu'on
puisse les contrôler parce qu'on savait
pas ken keen et chine
c'est le problème pour que ça marche les
la fermeture des frontières aériennes il
faut que tous les états membres à huy où
les états les bailleurs n'ont même temps
ça y est il a raison mais il se passe
qu'on perd le contrôle
on est incapable de tracer les gens
enfin c'est du bon sens quoi c'est du
beau mais pas mal mais monsieur vision
doit raconter des conneries faudra
réfléchir quarry bay merveilleux
maintenant c'est trois divisions
mais non c'est pas trop tard ce qu'il
vous fallait effectivement c'est pas
compliqué ils sont 10 à 20% en au
portugal
on est foutus c'est trop d'abord
effectivement il ya plusieurs notions
est-ce que ce variant brésilien c'est
quand même le thème de l'émission il
faut en avoir peur alors d'abord moi
j'ai une question j'ai entendu de victor
o expliqué que c'était très dangereux et
qu'on allait tous mourir ça j'ai compris
enfin vous résistez ag auprès de vous
alors oui alors ce que j'ai ici on vivra
alors compris qu'il ya quand même plus
si on s'en inquiète c'est qu'il est plus
dangereux plus contaminant et concerne
effectivement des patients plus jeunes
ouais bien
alors maintenant je te poser une
question quels sont tes sources et
pourquoi ta ta ta ta ta question m'a
écouté c'est bizarre parce que cyril
hanouna les mêmes sources quand il a
fait l'introduction non c'était qu'on
doit tromper tout pourquoi pas ce qu'est
ce que tu connais qui que 13 du code de
déontologie médicale
lorsque le médecin participent à une
action d'information du public de
caractère éducatif et sanitaire qu'elle
conçoit moyenne diffusion il le doit
faire état que de connaissances que de
données confirmées
oui la preuve de prudence oui voilà gens
ne s'y attendait pas de souci les
répercussions de ses alter ego du public
donc moi j'ai le média qui leur a tant
le domaine fr va la santé le nord est du
brésil
accompagné de tous les réanimateurs
qu'on fait cette publication mois les
questions mais attend que tu vérifier
entre le monde sa mais les soirées mots
ne le sera tant d'humanité
c'est comme moi je bosse ok mais attend
des fusées mois moi j'ai une étude un
trait print cette entreprise mais au
moins j'en ai une qui compare les âges
en réanimation des patients brésilien
entre mars 2020 et mars 2021
or on s'aperçoit que c'est les mêmes
tranches d'âge mais donc si tu as
d'autres donnez donnez moi et si tu
n'avais redonnant ludovic je te pose une
question et il va y répondre
je viens même pas mésestimer atteint
même pas je reviens même pas masquer les
symptômes et la bresse calme-toi tentera
de partir en cacahuète neige parfois
quitter la radio les gens dont je
voudrais pas on a ça et on a un vrai
danger qui marquait d'ailleurs c'est
sûrement pour ça que le portugal a fermé
tout le monde ferme on faire me faire
plaisir parce que les portugais ont
beaucoup de familles au brûlé voilà
pourquoi mais non sinon tu fais pas de
la science mais est-ce que je peux
occuper ma relation et je ne sais pas de
nation ça fait pas de la science et des
décisions les décisions gouvernementales
des gouvernements portugais s'appuie sur
des données médicales comme où la faune
et comme nous le font aussi en france
malgré d'inaki ciel pas au rendez vous
non m division sher fabrice tu peux dire
ce que tu veux que c'est faux que la
borne repas non les morts que je dis je
dis qu'il faut faire quelque chose et
faire quelque chose c'est faire comme si
on leur a dû fermer on pouvait pas faire
avec l'angleterre parce qu'on a quelques
minutes et on prend la voiture
la boîte c'est un avion il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'avions y en a 1000 ceux qui
viennent d'accord protesté à l'arrivée
on peut avoir 48 heures ça qu'on est
négatif à leur point de choc
c'était bien sûr mais se mettre juste 10
jours quelque part pour bloquer on peut
pas le faire en france ça n'existe pas
le meilleur moyen vu ce qui se passe et
vu surtout que je rappelle que cette
pandémie n'est pas maîtrisé en france
aujourd'hui parce qu'on arrive aux mêmes
chiffres et tu peux pas dire le
contraire paraît de perdre s'imposer
mais c'est la réponse de chanel qui
c'est quoi la cour immigrés la réponse
mais on a le droit on a le droit si vous
lâchez pas de changer tu gens pour des
missions à la nation la question c'est
est-ce que ce variant il faut en avoir
peur moi ce que je note d'ailleurs vous
détruit ou non en bon je dis pas ce que
je dois dire que vous avez arrêté
d'affoler les populations
il faut arrêter le marié anglais juin à
l'exemple de marion anglais ludovic
lemarié anglais qui le plus dangereux
que le variant que les autres vario le
var et en anglais puis dangereux parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de bol mais les bleus
comptaient choix avec ton pote bob
annonces football
ecoute-moi syphilis parce que des gens
nous écoutent aujourd'hui aider
du désolé serait le succès rivaz vd dont
le père il on va dire une chose
un virus soissons qui de toute façon et
plus compter jeu sera forcément plus
mortel et non à je peux finir non tu ne
peux pas vous dire quand il va devenir
médecin moi mes arguments c'est pas les
miens je m'évertue à dire ici que mon
argument on s'en fout c'est ce
qu'espèrent les métairies une étude
anglaise a au nom des populations depuis
trois mois en disant que le variant
angles a été plus mortel et là moi je
dis depuis trois mois
ici ailleurs que j'ai lu les données
statistiques anglaise et qu'il n'y a pas
de formes plus grave du variant anglais
elle disait non laissez les données
hospitalières anglaise je ne comprenais
pas comment c'était possible je vais
laisser attend tout à coup deux études
viennent de paraître jeune et brillant
vainqueur feu viennent de paraître
on s'est même fait l'écho qui disent ah
bah on s'est peut-être trompé en fait le
vario anglais n'est peut-être pas si
dangereux sans réelle et le dérailleur
brésilien pour vous est-ce qu'il est
plus dangereux n'en sais rien mais aussi
je n'essaie pas de fortis auraient mais
non on va quand même y ont violé à milan
mais d'abord on évite de parler d'un
état qu'on ne connaît pas
connaissez vous des maîtres division là
vous n'avez jamais été autant cinglé
ces normes de coire et reda vous avez
non mais attendez vous parlez anglais
vous parler portugais vous nous parlez
de boney m puis un visa par conséquent
les mots lancés brésil via des canaux
réinfection évisions ce klaus a rien
fait les piles et gyan qui ont été
vaccinés les quelques excès pour y
ranger votre dossier où il rien dedans
risée du monde entier
c'est quelqu'un que vous avez fait là
par les fabricants dont on peut rire ici
c'est vous n'en seriez vous dire
pourquoi on peut rire je joue parce que
vous ne savez rien parce que vous ne
connaissez rien et que vous êtes là
juste effectivement pour faire de la
bonne animation et un peu de buzz
la vérité c'est qu'effectivement vous
lui avez très justement dit des gens
meurent on est parfaitement venir et
attendait et aux gens qui meurent il ya
une chose qu'on doit c'est la vérité oui
mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya des mordus
coville qu'il faut qu'elle est mort de
peur ces premières premièrement et
deuxièmement mort c'est pas affolant les
populations que vous allez réussir à
régler quoi que ce soit monsieur dire
aujourd'hui le problème que vous avez
sur vos plateaux c'est que vous racontez
n'importe quoi que j'aime beaucoup
ludovic mais ils doivent ils se
présentent à vous avec des données qui
sont partielles avec des données qui ne
sont pas les données de la science alors
volé mon poney quoi moi ce que je ferai
la première chose que j'ai à vous dire
je vais aller au gré des commandes ce
que recommandent les épidémiologistes en
pareille matière parce que c'est pas la
première épidémie qu'on traverse c'est
exactement de faire ce qu'on fait à
venise au moyen-âge salle et nous ça
vient le mot isolés par la gondole isolé
cette saga
ça vient d'eux isola qu est une île
parce qu'au moyen-âge
ils seront admises en fait mais les
délais les gens qui arrivaient en mettez
est donc arrivé aujourd'hui ce qu'on
pourrait faire c'est quoi une demande d
israël les gens qui viennent en france
eh ben effectivement on les soumet un
test pcr on les met en quarantaine en
france faire puisqu'on sait pas s'il est
en avant on dénote quarantaine en france
on le fait et on arrête de commenter et
on arrête d'affoler les populations et
on arrête de dire le variant angles est
le mari en sucre brésilien le marion
nord-américain est vachement plus grave
on va tous mourir fois les rôles et si
l'on parlait le temps ça c'est bon pour
l'audimat c'est bon pour les chaînes
d'info mais derrière il ya des gens qui
meurent là il ya des gens qui jouent à
trouille mais alors jamais donné qu'est
ce que vous répondez à travailler répond
déjà balle et d'isoler relisent ollie
smith que c'est pas dangereux à sa fille
maintenant on va dire on va dire une
chose très claire
ça veut d'être tous les chefs doré à
tous les épidémiologistes qui dit tout
le contraire aujourd'hui feraient une
sorte de cabale et qui tout le monde
mais attend des aidants fabrice il faut
comme on le dit aurait dû me dit ou
s'écrit tous oui attend ainsi que
fabrice deux mois d'après fabrice il
faut un peu d'humilité mi temps où les
chefs de service bar avicenne lesquels
arrête mais ravi à quelques heures
d'avis a nommé le chef d'avicenne
professeur à l'ena et hec
résigné et pénales probant à temps plein
c'est plutôt chez vous dire qu'il ya des
problèmes
il est le problème à chaque fois sur ce
plateau c'est qu'on fait de l'émotionnel
le débat rationnel de l'émotionnel tout
mais en l'occurrence moi tu me dis que
le mariage est refusée pic à dubai en
brie jeudi à bree plus dangereux arrête
de me jeter ou donner des leçons
d'émotion je te produis moi je vais te
répondre
je réponds tu veux te réponds tu sais on
a vu une tarification dames et courait
dans tous les sens parler on a eu une
altercation derrière fois parce qu'il
mettait en doute jetez pas médecin iront
serait peu fruité tous les fous ils
râlent à vous mais je suis médecin et je
veux repartir vacciner j'ai vu des gens
de surcoûts mourir parce que les deux
fois fini en forêt pour mélanie
recommandée datée dans l'agitation la
tête dans l'agitation
si on pose c'est pas grave quand on en
avait beaucoup évolué et je vous le dis
comme je le pense
avec toute l'amitié ce que tu penses
bien ensemble mais sans annoncer que je
ne m'en sens on s'en fout me laisser
tomber
on se connaît on se connaît depuis
longtemps tu vois et ce genre de débat
qu'il a changé l'histoire n'est pas bon
n'est pas mal parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous écoutent
non ma chérie et le message annappes et
le message qu'on a apporté aujourd'hui
c'est pure il faut qu'on s'en sort parce
qu'on nous a annoncé le 15 mai et c'est
mal barré
que tu sois pas d'accord mais c'est pas
moins partielle de neige n'est pas moi
vous savez jamais si effectivement vous
avez tous à l'orgueil des ménages et les
ventes de produits fabriqués qui l'a
tant que produit une étude générale avec
une bride quoi tu venu à fabriquer riou
fait j'aurais tout le monde se trompe il
ya que toi qui es d'accord si tout le
monde oui à 68% des voix là excusez moi
mais moi voilà excuse moi ça je suis ce
que c'est ça mais c'est air peur aux
gens des portugais qui sont touchées ça
veut dire que le bail en vérité c'est
que vous en savez rien et quoi merci en
fin d'année - si oui vous viennent me
traiter parce que médicalement il fut
rien merci fabrice vidéo